[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 culture au sommaire
aujourd'hui le spectacle les voyageurs
du crime étaient accueillis en résidence
au théâtre de la celle saint cloud
pendant dix jours comédien et metteur en
scène au travail et les aspects
techniques et artistiques
nous nous sommes rendus à l'une des
répétitions une exposition pour
représenter versailles dans la bande
dessinée elle est visible au château
jusqu'au 31 décembre
l'événement met en avant le travail de
40 auteurs et illustrateurs une centaine
de planches de bd sont à découvrir
et puis le festival imag on revient pour
une troisième édition
objectif promouvoir les oeuvres
d'artistes en situation de handicap mais
aussi leur permettre d'accéder à la
culture
au programme théâtre marionnettes danse
ou encore au cinéma et je vous le disais
en titre tout à l'heure le spectacle les
voyageurs du crime étaient accueillants
résidence du théâtre de la celle saint
cloud nous avons rencontré l'équipe lors
de leur premier filage le 23 septembre
dernier une résidence pour mettre en
scène leur spectacle les voyageurs du
crime
comédien et metteur en scène étaient
présents théâtre de la celle saint cloud
au mois de septembre
objectif travailler l'aspect artistique
et poto nik vraiment entrée de
coordination etc
c'est pour ça que les résidences sont
très importantes et que c'est très
belles opportunités que nous offre les
villes ça permet vraiment d'avancé sur
un travail qui est très lourd et seront
très compliqués à faire au dernier
moment et l'avantagent d'une résidence
et que ça offre quelques jours voire une
semaine ou dix jours comme l'a par
exemple à la celle saint cloud où
on peut travailler aisément leur passage
au théâtre de la celle-saint-cloud aura
duré une dizaine de jours
l'occasion de faire un premier filage et
de s'attarder sur les détails pour la
première fois on va faire ce qu'on
appelle le boutabout le premier filage
pour voir avec toute la mise en scène
qu'on a calé cette semaine on essaye les
costumes pour voir s'il ya des soucis et
puis on essaye un petit peu avec des
accessoires aussi qu'on a pour se
dépatouiller un peu tout voir comment
est-ce qu'on pose les choses des
chapeaux les manteaux les voilà c'est
une première premiers débuts de travail
c'est important pour nous et
comportements mais ma mère les débuts là
et on va vers le spectacle et la suite
du cercle de whitechapel
les personnages se retrouvent quelques
années après dans l'orient-express est
là conan doyle et plus connus d'u10 en
forcément temps avant il a écrit
beaucoup beaucoup de succès et plus
établi voilà bon il est veuf et donc ses
amis ont décidé de l'emmener dans un
long voyage afin de lui changer les
idées sauf que dans ce voyage il va se
passer beaucoup de choses assez étrange
une disparition voilà ce qui attend les
personnages du spectacle une équipe
composée de personnages ayant existé va
se mettre à l'enquêté à savoir bram
stocker qui était l'auteur de dracula
arthur conan doyle l'auteur de sherlock
holmes et george bernard shaw qui était
un journaliste mais également auteur de
théâtre une représentation du spectacle
et voyageurs du crime aura lieu au
théâtre de la celle saint cloud en avril
l'artiste voit pose y sera présente ce
samedi à 10 octobre à la librairie le
pavé du canal de montigny le bretonneux
elle présentera son conte poétique et
musical cassia et le voyage des saisons
un conte ludique qui s'adresse aux
enfants dans lequel elle fait vivre des
marionnettes
[Musique]
moi je vais narrer le conte pour les
enfants et je vais faire aussi vivre les
marionnettes dans ce conte avec la voix
qui est propre à chaque marionnette dix
mois un grimpeur
pourquoi il fait ils tombent des arbres
c'est parce que seul ou tôt le tone
yuppies habiller la forêt pour lui
permettre de dormir quand on consomme
petit nous allons être très réceptifs à
l'environnement on va dire magique du
compte maintenant lorsque les enfants
sont plus grands ils peuvent comprendre
la totalité du compte
et lorsque nous sommes adultes nous
pouvons comprendre aussi le symbolisme
du compte puisque dans chacun de mes
comptes
il y a quelque chose de symboliquement
très fort les enfants ne ne
s'interdisent pas d'imaginer et de rêver
et le ce que j'utilise comme comme on va
dire comme being in line pour le monde
magique de posy c'est la citation de
john meyer qui nous dit que
l'imagination a le pouvoir de nous
rendre infini du monde magique de poésie
est une production que j'ai créée qu'une
production à 100 % française est
totalement indépendante et la librairie
le bal et du canal partagent une même
valeur
donc c'est sur ce point là que nous
sommes rentrés le comte cassia et le
voyage des saisons sera donc à la
librairie le pavé du canal de montigny
le bretonneux poesy vous y attendra le
10 octobre à 16 heures à 17 heures et 18
heures l'événement sera suivi d'une
séance de dédicaces
réservation obligatoire sur le site
internet le monde magique de posy une
exposition pour représenter versailles
dans la bande dessinée la célèbre salle
du jeu de paume de versailles a été
aménagé pour accueillir à l'installation
elle retraçait la représentation du
château par une quarantaine d'auteurs et
de dessinateurs un reportage d' astrid
berges et patrice jack de dix minutes et
bixente mes liens sont tissés balle ce
sont plus d'une centaine de planches
mise à la disposition du public depuis
le 19 septembre dernier dans la salle du
jeu de paume elles témoignent d'un lien
étroit entre le château de vayres
l'univers de la bande dessinée cette
exposition qui est présente une centaine
de planches et consacrée dans à
versailles dans la bande dessinée elle
permet de montrer comment une
quarantaine d'artistes différents l'ont
appréhendé à leur manière le château de
versailles comment ils représentaient
avec leurs techniques propres et leur
sensibilité
les pièces sont présentées dans le cadre
de l'année de la bd décrétée par le
ministère de la culture
l'occasion d'effectuer une rétrospective
historique originale la bande dessinée
historique a connu un grand regain
d'intérêt depuis une quarantaine
d'années et beaucoup d'événements se
passe justement souvent ces régimes donc
au château de versailles
il ya des planches qui sont consacrés
aux intrigues de la cour sous le 14 ou
le 15 ou le 16 à la vie de cour
au fait qu'ils pouvaient été donnée à
versailles ou promenade dans les jardins
de nombreuses planches sont consacrés à
la révolution française que représente
symboliquement la salle du jeu de paume
c'est pourquoi elle a été choisie pour
héberger l'exposition cette scène a été
choisi parce que son format était
parfait idéal pour accueillir ces
centaines de planches de la manière dont
elles sont présentées mais également
parce que il à cette grande toile qui
est face à moi qui était composé d'après
le dessin de jacques louis david
représentant le serment du jeu de paume
qui lui même est presque un dessin pour
une bande dessinée
l'exposition est gratuite accessible
tous les jours sauf le lundi jusqu'au 31
décembre
un événement qui présente des oeuvres
d'artistes en situation de handicap le
festival ima goâve et handicap se
déroule jusqu'au 20 décembre prochain ce
sera dans toute l'île de france
notamment dans les yvelines pour en
parler sur ce plateau célia garçons
gobons soir en soir le festival veut
montrer qu'on peut faire un grand
événement autour de la culture et du
handicap
oui l'essentiel de la programmation est
construite par des artistes en situation
de handicap quel que soit le handicap et
quel que soit le genre artistique tous
les visiteurs sont bien sûr les
bienvenus
valide comme handicapé et l'idée c'est
véritablement d'inclure les artistes en
situation de handicap les mettre en
lumière et leur permettre
l'accessibilité des plateaux ils font
bouger les esthétiques d'après le co
directeur du festival leur handicap
les obligea à proposer de nouveaux
gestes artistiques
si je prends tout simplement la langue
des signes par exemple
il ya des spectacles avec des personnes
qui s'y sur un plateau ils font du chant
signe concert avec uniquement le cinéma
c'est quelque chose alors on roule à on
les aurait pas on n'aurait pas pu
l'inventer cru c'est dire quelle serait
la programmation du festival tous les
départements de l'île de france seront
représentés mais essentiellement le
département du val d'oise et celui des
yvelines alors par exemple on retrouve
un spectacle qui s'appelle certains
regardent les étoiles qui parle de la
surdité et qui sera joué dans quatre
salles yvelinoise il y aura quatre
spectacles comme gargantua de rabelais
le 8 décembre à la ferme de bel ébat ou
10 l'ex qui parle du trouble de la
dyslexie le 1er décembre toujours à la
ferme du bel ébat et puis j'aimerais
qu'on s'attarde sur l'exposition
collective
regards croisés ou ces artistes valides
et handicapés expose une cinquantaine
d'oeuvres autour de trois axes qui parle
du corps le corps visible le corps
vécues et le corps social
l'accessibilité on l'a aussi penser dans
le cadre de voilà du propos de
l'exposition parler du corps bien sûr
c'est une manière d'évoquer le handicap
mais aussi de voir comment le vécu du
corps pour une personne en situation de
handicap finalement résonne avec la
manière dont on vit chacun notre corps
donc arriver à faire quelque chose d'un
clusif véritablement ccr mots un mot
important dans ta en tout cas la manière
dont on a conçu cette exposition est
sûre ce festival tous les handicaps
seront représentés oui tous les
handicaps aussi bien physique que
psychique ou encore mental il n'y a pas
de limites on voit bien 10 l'ex par
exemple est ce que c'est le handicap un
aussi mais voilà on peut être dit sexy
qui est tout à fait dans la vie
avec des responsabilités avec tout ça
donc oui tous les handicaps tout ce qui
fait handicap tout ce qui nous empêche
un moment donnée d'accéder à peut être
présent dans notre festival est je le
rappelle tous ces événements ne sont pas
réservées essentiellement aux personnes
en situation de handicap
tout le monde est invité à découvrir ses
oeuvres et ses spectacles jusqu'au 20
décembre prochain eh bien on ira avec
plaisir merci c'est d'avoir été avec
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
dans la prochaine émission
oui toujours dans le domaine du festival
l'association omani croiser le cinoche
organise en partenariat avec ville de
magny les hameaux sa première édition du
festival de courts métrages sur
smartphone un événement qui se déroulera
le vendredi 16 octobre à 20 heures à la
maison de l'environnement
tout de suite on regarde une
bande-annonce de l'un des courts
métrages dans un port
[Musique]
si personne passait une fin d'après midi
plus tôt
tranquille un virus mortel circulent
rester enfermé vont devoir vivre
ensemble brevets tellement des mauvaises
ou pas et on reste on est dans la
musique avec amour humain amour divin et
c'est le nom du concert qui sera donné
par la claveciniste marie van lines la
musicienne propose un récital chanter
pour clôturer sa résidence au centre de
musique baroque de versailles
la représentation se déroulera le 11
octobre à 16 heures à l'église d'où dans
l église ou d'un oui donc ce sera assez
la fin de de 7,8 culture merci nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et puis deux nouvelles sorties
culturelles en attendant se quittent sur
un extrait de musique de la musicienne
marie van rijn bonne soirée à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]